would you cut well let me explain we
said outside areas like education and
health key protected areas there are
going to be reductions in spending and
we set out some of those cuts like the
winter fuel allowance for pensioners
earn with incomes over 42,000 pounds a
year
we've talked about the ways in which we
will a cut money from through
efficiencies in the police in local
government we've said for example that
child benefit will be restricted to 1%
we said will will reverse thing what
does that come to what the the figures
is one hundred at least hundreds of
millions more than a hundred billion
pounds but look that's not the point
because let me explain we are going to
make we're gonna have to make these
decisions when we're in government but
I've got to set out an overall approach
and I have set out an overall approach
I'll set an overall approach which says
as I said earlier it's about their taxes
it's about on the labor leader going
into the election saying we're going to
reduce spending outside a small minority
various Tony Blair never went into an
election saying that but what Tony Blair
did is Tony Blair's affair isn't it no
it's a point about it's a point about my
approach Jeremy I'm not denying the need
I'm not denying the need I'll be
defending be greater no it would fall
we've also been less thing towards they
don't borrow more than that they're
gonna be they're gonna be reductions in
alone in outside the protected
departments we can be reducing spending
yes I'm talk about overall spending
overall spending would not increase it
would decrease these Laurel is likely to
fall yeah like clean up it's a bit of a
weasel word loudly isn't it I'm setting
out the direction of travel I'm saying
input okay I'm confused about various of
your policies as well as is obvious